>> Jon: WELCOME BACK.
EARLIER THIS WEEK, JORDAN
KLEPPER HE GAVE US PART ONE OF
HIS COMPLETE COVERAGE OF THE
U.K. ELECTIONS.
IN TONIGHT'S PART TWO, HE NOW
COMPLETES HIS COMPLETE COVERAGE
COMPLETELY.
JORDAN.
>> LAST WEEK IN THE U.K., THE
CONSERVATIVE PARTY HAD A HUGE
VICTORY.
I ASSUME BY USING THE SAME WEDGE
ISSUES AMERICAN CONSERVATIVE
CANDIDATES USE SO EXCERPTLY.
>> WELL, I DO BELIEVE LIFE
BEGINS AT CONCEPTION.
>> GOVERNMENT-RUN HEALTH CARE.
THIS IS WHAT I WOULD DO TO THAT
LAW.
>> I THINK MARRIAGE IS BETWEEN
A MAN AND A WOMAN.
>> HOW AM I GOING TO WIN?
AND I SAID GUNS.
>> OBVIOUSLY THESE SAME ISSUES
WOULD RESONATE IN BRITAIN.
HOW IMPORTANT IS THE GUN ISSUE
FOR YOU?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE ANY GUNS HERE?
>> NO, DOES THAT UPSET YOU?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, HOW DO YOU
SHOOT LEGISLATION
YOU DON'T LIKE?
>> WE VOTE IT DOWN.
>> IS SOCIALIZED MEDICINE
GETTING THROWN DOWN
YOUR THROATS?
>> NO, WE ALREADY HAVE IT.
>> HOW BIG OF AN ISSUE IS
ABORTION?
>> THE MAIN PARTIES ARE ALL
THINKING THE SAME THING ON THAT.
>> WHAT ABOUT GAY MARRIAGE?
>> THAT'S ALSO NOT A DEBATE.
WE HAVE IT, AND NO ONE, IT'S ALL
FINE.
>> SO WHAT THE [BLEEP] DO YOU
GUYS TALK ABOUT?
>> WE TALK ABOUT THE ECONOMY. WE
TALK ABOUT SOMETHING CALLED THE
DEFICIT --
>> BORING.
MAYBE POLITICAL CONSULTANT STEVE
MORGAN CAN TELL US WHY THEY'RE
IGNORING THESE KEY ISSUES.
>> WELL, I MEAN, WE WOULD ARGUE
WE DEAL WITH THE
REAL ISSUES HERE AND THOSE ARE
NOT THOSE.
>> IS THERE ANY PARTY OUT
THERE THAT'S TALKING ABOUT THE
FUN, WILD CARD STUFF,
LIKE CLIMATE DENIERS OR
ANTI-IMMIGRATION OR BIG FEARS
AND STUFF LIKE THAT?
>> WELL, WE'VE
GOT ANTI-IMMIGRATION FROM THE
UKIP PARTY.
>> UKIP? WHAT IS THAT?
>> THE U.K. INDEPENDENCE PARTY.
AND THEY'RE A VERY DANGEROUS
PARTY BECAUSE
THEY'RE XENOPHOBIC.
THEY APPEAL TO THE WORST
ELEMENTS OF BRITISH SOCIETY.
>> OKAY, THAT'S A PARTY I
UNDERSTAND.
THAT SOUND LIKE GOOD OLD
AMERICAN CAMPAIGNING.
BUT WAS UCIP CANDIDATE KIM ROSE
ABLE TO WALK THE FINE LINE
BETWEEN EXPLOITING PEOPLE'S
FEARS AND BALD-FACED HATRED?
>> YOU KNOW, WE'RE NOT RACIST.
WE WANT TO STOP THE MASS
MIGRATION OF PEOPLE COMING INTO
THIS COUNTRY.
THEY'RE COMING OVER IN VAST
NUMBERS AND NOW YOU'VE GOT
COMMUNITIES TAKING UP PARTS OF
THE TOWN WHICH ARE ALL FULL OF
LIKE POLISH PEOPLE.
>> SEE, HE'S NOT RACIST.
HE JUST DOESN'T LIKE POLISH
PEOPLE.
>> I'M NOT A RACIST. WHAT I'M
TRYING TO PROVE IS AN ACTUAL
FACT, YOU KNOW, THIS ISN'T
ABOUT RACE.
THIS IS ABOUT SPACE.
ALL WE WANT IS OUR COUNTRY BACK.
>> IF YOU'RE NOT REPEATEDLY
DEFENDING THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE BEING CALLED A RACIST
OVER AND OVER AGAIN,
YOU'RE DOING SOMETHING WRONG.
>> ABSOLUTELY, ABSOLUTELY, I AM
NOT.
>> NOT RACIST! THAT'S WHAT I'M
SAYING.
>> I AM NOT.
>> I CAN'T THINK OF ANY REASON
WHY PEOPLE WERE CONFUSED
ABOUT HIS POLICIES.
>> I GOT IN TROUBLE FOR A HITLER
COMMENT.
SO I QUOTED FROM THE BOOK OF
"MEIN KAMPF."
>> THE NAZI REFERENCE, GOOD
IDEA.
ALTHOUGH WE DON'T USUALLY
ACTUALLY QUOTE HILTLER.
SOUNDS LIKE HE WAS READY FOR
AMERICAN-STYLE POLITICS.
HE JUST NEEDED A COUPLE OF
POINTERS FROM A PRO.
>> THEY'VE TAKEN AWAY OUR POLICE
FORCE.
THEY'VE TAKEN AWAY OUR
ARMY.
>> GIVE HER THE WORST-CASE
SCENARIO.
>> THE WORST-CASE SCENARIO IS
THIS GREAT, GREAT COUNTRY WILL
CEASE TO EXIST.
>> NICE.
>> YOU KNOW ABOUT THE U.K.
POLICIES?
>> HIT HER WITH THE HUNDRED
YEARS OF DARKNESS.
>> YEAH, IF WE DON'T GET OUT OF
THE E.U., OUR CHILDREN
AND OUR GRANDCHILDREN WILL HAVE
100 YEARS OF DARKNESS.
>> THIS GUY WAS ON FIRE.
BUT THEN HIS TOUGHEST CHALLENGE.
SQUARING OFF WITH THE RIVAL
CANDIDATE FROM THE GREEN PARTY.
>> YEAH LOOK, THE FACT IS, AT
THE END OF THE DAY,
WE ARE THE ONLY PARTY THAT WANTS
A COMPLETE WITHDRAWAL FROM
THE EUROPEAN UNION.
>> WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> AND I KNOW YOU CAN'T SEE
THAT.
>> MAKE THE HITLER REFERENCE
AGAIN.
>> YEAH, HITLER IN
1942, IN "MEIN KAMPF" --
>> GOOD!
>> SAID THAT THEY WILL TAKE
AWAY OUR FREEDOM IN TINY,
INTO PIECES.
NOW THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> BOOM! WALK AWAY. JUST, GOOD,
GOOD.
>> ULTIMATELY, KIM ROSE ENDED UP
WITH A WHOPPING 13% OF THE VOTE,
WHICH SEEMS LIKE WAY MORE THAN
HE DESERVED.
AND ACTUALLY, IN THE TIME I
SPENT HERE IN BRITAIN, APART
FROM THEIR TERRIBLE VERSION OF
BASEBALL, I WAS IMPRESSED WITH
THEIR ELECTORAL SYSTEM.
GUYS LIKE THIS ARE MAGINALIZED.
THEY SPEND LITTLE ON THE
ELECTIONS.
THEY HAD JUST SIX WEEKS TO
CAMPAIGN, AND THEIR NEWS MEDIA
PROVIDES REASONABLY SOBER
ANALYSIS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> BUT THERE WAS STILL SOMETHING
THAT WAS BOTHERING ME.
WHAT WAS IT.
>> ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH THE
IRAQ WAR?
>> THE IRAQ WAR?
THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU GUYS WERE INVOLVED IN THAT,
TOO.
>> YEAH, WE WERE THERE.
>> YOU GUYS HAVE MADE SOME
[BLEEP] BONEHEAD MOVES.
>> YEAH.
>> ALL RIGHT, LIKE US, THEY
FOUGHT AN UNNECESSARY WAR.
THEIR GOVERNMENT APPROVAL
RATINGS ARE DISMAL.
AND BRITISH LEADERS EVEN
PROMISED PUNISHING AUSTERITY
MEASURES. SO APPARENTLY, NO
MATTER YOUR ELECTORAL SYSTEM,
YOUR GOVERNMENT WILL FIND
A WAY TO [BLEEP] IT ALL UP.
OR COURSE, IF YOU'RE BRITISH
THERE IS A CULTURAL
ADVANTAGE THAT CANNOT BE DENIED.
>> HEY, AND JORDAN WE ALSO USE
THE WORD [BLEEP].
IT'S NOT A PROBLEM HERE, SO
CHEERS!
HERE'S TO THE POLITICS.
>> WE DO.
>> HEY [BLEEP]!
>> [BLEEP].
>> GOOD DAY, [BLEEP].
>> HEY, [BLEEP]!
>> [BLEEP]!
>> Jon: JORDAN KLEPPER,
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )